we are here with Diane Hendricks she's a
woman of many titles she's an active
owner of ABC Supply and she is one of
America's richest self-made women and on
this year's 50 over 50. Diane thank you
so much for having us
thank you for having me I want to start
you have such a fascinating story
including you grew up on a dairy farm
and you've previously told Forbes that
growing up on this Farm you are not
allowed to milk a cow or drive a tractor
is that correct that's correct why is
that
um well I'm one of Nine Girls and my
father I just think felt that it was
safer he was always worried about us
kids girls being in the farm I think he
always wanted boys probably would have
stopped at two but went on to have nine
girls
um
he just had us do little little tasks
large tasks were for the men and the
young men that he would hire to do the
hard work on the farm but you learned
hard work growing up on this Farm I
learned to work but I didn't I didn't
work around Machinery I think it's just
the way he was he just he was a man's
man and he didn't say that women
belonged in the house but he also didn't
encourage
getting into
business
like men what do you think you never
save your business right now my father
actually was very proud of me he passed
about uh
oh 20 years ago
but he knew of our successes skins and
mine with ABC and other businesses and
he quietly was very proud very very
proud
now you've also said that you had to
grow up very quickly what does that mean
to you and why do you say that I got
pregnant when I was just about 17 years
old
and
my parents encouraged me basically told
me you need to marry the father
of your son my baby at the time and I
did even though it was not a
it was popular but not love he was a
good man and it only lasted for three
years
and uh that's when I really started to
look at a career and a career I had
always dreamed of having which was being
in business since I wasn't allowed to be
on the farm but to be engaged in
something that I wanted to and I always
pictured myself in blue suit
and uh having a nice car and being
independent so what was your first job
oh my goodness I had a few little jobs I
worked at Parker Pen a little bit for
like three months and then the really
job that I really decided this is going
to be my future is I started to get
involved in real estate and before I was
21 years old and you could actually sit
in a model home you could sell real
estate off from a set of prints it
wasn't really real estate because it
wasn't really dirt
it was a speck on a piece of paper so
you're selling paper so I got involved
in that and then eventually I got my
real estate license and I met Ken
and uh
he bought a couple houses two houses for
seven thousand dollars
and I did the work and cleaned them and
rented them and that started a
relationship
of buying real estate in Beloit
Wisconsin
and um that's how it all started I was I
was divorced and lived in a little
apartment
and uh sold real estate I uh was a
Playboy bunny
and I don't hide the fact it's a
glorified waitress and uh
it helped me to be able to pursue my
career which was real estate and I was
over there for about a year
and you know making enough money to
raise the Sun
you got to do what you got to do you do
what you got to do and I didn't ask my
parents my parents give me 200 and I
paid them back in 90 days I'm I'm
independent and I'm I'm proud of what I
I work for and I earn
and I still have those same values I
pass it on to my children they've all
worked my grandchildren
they know I'm not happy unless they've
had they got a job
I uh I think there's no better feeling
than earning working and earning it is a
feeling of satisfaction and I pursued
that my whole life
well you and Ken were business partners
and life Partners but let's talk about
building a business together when did
ABC Supply begin and how Ken and I were
together for like 15 years he was a
roofing contractor and I really was
warmed I was the real estate person and
uh buying we owned a lot of homes in
Beloit
and that is the city that really gave us
our start Ken had lived in Janesville
and had a piece of real estate and uh he
called himself an entrepreneur which was
a word that now is used in everyday
language for years and they asked again
if he knew what an entrepreneur was and
it was it was kind of a funny
conversation because they said it's a
risk taker and we don't do business with
Risk Takers and so that kind of halted
his banking in Janesville and we started
to make and was bloat savings back at
the time and they gave us a start and it
truly is the city that made all the
difference to Ken and I they were a
giving community
and I I still I still call it home and
I've done a lot to help the community
and that's really important to me to
give back because they gave us that
chance
you never forget the people you don't
need you you really don't you really
don't I want to talk to you about
building this business so you've built
ABC Supply with Ken until 2007. right
Ken was a roofer when I met him he had a
roofing Contracting firm that was local
in Madison and in in the Janesville area
and probably five years after I knew Ken
we started doing government work
for the military many nights with big
prints laying all over
trying to determine
what we're going to bid to get one of
those jobs
and they were they were large contracts
and uh I always say we either made money
on it or we lost and it was it was an
open bid process and if you weren't
if you were a little bitter and you were
really low you worried a lot and uh
so we did that for quite a long time we
realized that the need in the our
industry the roofing industry but the
manufacturers each of them they were the
manufacturers of it but they were also
the distributor if you wanted that kind
of shingles you bought it from the
manufacturer there was no distribution
chain Across the Nation so there was
little pockets of where the products
were manufactured and that's you
generally bought from the manufacturer
that was in your area
and as we were roofing contractors in
the military they would spec products
that you couldn't get in the areas where
they were building where they were
asking you to provide product and you
just start looking at the need and over
the course of five ten years we realized
that there needed to be a distribution
chain to be able to offer to the
customer us the contractor the selection
of various manufacturing products Across
the Nation and so we pursued that
and finally put together a plan I
remember it took us like two years
to put together the plan and how do we
start Where Do We Begin to be a
distributor of roofing products
and so we we practiced on a wholesale
store that sold products for real estate
people just to see what it was like and
from there we decided we were ready a
couple years later and we opened up
store one for ABC Supply
with products that we brought in
shingles from different manufacturers we
were in business for about three years
just buying up lumber yards a couple
here a couple there
and when we heard
that GAF was going to sell off
their roofing division and I know Ken
and I were on vacation and we flew home
and went up and met with jaf and two
young people that had never been to New
York and negotiated to buy 13 of their
stores
and uh and we accomplish that it feels
like you and Ken really identified an
opening in the market how did you do
that what what were you seeing
because there was no distribution for
contractors and we were had been a
contractor for years and it was just we
need to have a distribution chain to be
able to carry all the products and we
wanted to bring professionalism to the
industry that we had come out of as a
contractor
and it was we felt we weren't being
traded with respect we were roofers
and we that was part of our goal was to
build a company
that would take the guy in the pickup
truck
and and provide service and respect
to all of them
and we built that our model on growing
ABC and we finally laid it out and
that's when we started to buy you know
two
about two of the first we bought we
built one and then we bought two and
then we started to grow but it was
always to carry those products that
would make it easy Across the Nation but
would also we would be giving that
contractor the respect that he needed
and we would give him we were at their
Bank we would set up terms which they'd
never had before so they could grow
so we we did everything that we could to
make the contractor have what we hadn't
been provided for as contractors
so that was then and then I know your
business has grown quite a bit in the
last two to three years what's been the
Catalyst for that growth do you think
we've done Acquisitions we continue to
grow by it we do green fields also but
we grow by acquisition we've been the
largest in the nation and the company is
40 years old now
41 years old is ABC so it's always about
is there a need where do you put a store
you know it's it's always about the need
and how you feel a need
and and you know we had 17
000 people working for ABC now
and we give them opportunity to go up
the ladder also it's not just come here
and this is what you're going to be
we've got management sales I mean it's
we built a great company with a lot of
great people you know the other
companies we have those same
goals and opportunities we've got 3 500
employees that work for manufacturing
the construction
all of the other
16 companies that we own
and good management and it really it
boils down to having the right people in
the right positions
so that they can lead it's such an
important part of running a company or
multiple companies
is hiring the right people
and some people miss that you've been
smart with your Acquisitions I want to
jump ahead I think that was a Savvy
strategy you employed during the 2008
financial crisis obviously not a good
time for housing the housing market the
market that depends on the goods that
that you sell can you talk about what
you did then because you have referred
to it as the biggest risk you've ever
taken well I lost my husband in seven
but you could feel that recession coming
on
it was it was very scary
very very scary
so it really became evident that we were
in a recession in late of 2008 2009.
and we had about 250 locations at that
time but the recession was
um we just
buckle down
really buckle down
and uh you know did what you do in a
recession you know you cut back on this
get back on that
but there was a acquisition that came
available
and it was Bradco
and there was no way
I could oversee that acquisition at that
time I had to take on a partner
an investment partner and I had to give
up 40 some percent of my shares
and uh
we've always owned everything but this
one was
one that I knew that I knew the company
and it had to be done and it it really
is painful to give a give up control and
to bring in investment bankers
but we structured that if I could give
them the return like they always want to
return within five years
I would buy my shares back
did you buy your shares back yes
we bought them back in three three and a
half years and I still get shippers
right now
because I felt I had risked the company
that I wanted my children to run when
we're not here you know it's it's not a
company that's ever going to be for sale
um it's a strong company we changed the
industry the whole nation now is has a
distributor in between you can buy any
product any place in the nation
manufacturers aren't running you know
the regional
distribution of of materials
and
it makes the the choice
and the contract everything better it
really really was an amazing thing that
we did by starting out with two stores
and three stores and distributing
various manufactured products
that's what made ABC so powerful but to
make that acquisition at that time
during a recession
was I was felt like I was risking it all
but I knew that I knew that it was a
good company we were buying and it's
proven to be one of the best
Acquisitions we ever did you can't see
into the future
you can't see that far into the future
so it was it was it was difficult but
great team I have I have a great team
had a great team then
and everybody believed that we could get
it done NIU you have to trust trust your
experts within the companies that we
have and we did it you take risks but
you take calculated risks
you know I always say you you don't take
risks that you can't afford to lose
yourself you don't want to hurt somebody
else in the in the
in the mistaking that you take
and I've never let
anybody down by that
my risk is going to hurt me
and I'll figure out how to don't take
more risk than you can afford to pay
back yourself
so if that was to fail that's one of
those
scary situations but we had built a
strong enough company that I knew that
we could
and we did how many stores do you have
today or how big is 900
and if you had to summarize what has
made the company so successful we've
talked about acquisition and following
your intuition what do you think the
secret to your success has been
hiring great people surrounding myself
with people of good integrity
knowing knowing the need of the
different businesses you know that I've
invested in
it's um
it's about the people you know we did it
because we knew there was a need in the
industry
but we also knew that we had to build
the best company
we're the best people we could find
and we did
and we still we still have
we're the best company in America I
think because of the people that we that
make it up
people always make the difference they
make all the difference in the world you
and Ken seem to have a real true
partnership in every sense of the word
and I recognize that but I'm also
curious because this business
has so many elements to it and you've
also made investments in Beloit what's
your baby what's Diane's best idea
well ABC will always be
what we call our lead
and it's by far the biggest company
and um
but we were in construction
still have the same company
we started buying
I mean real estate
it is my passion we have Development
Across the Nation now
um Beloit you know it's a
for me in the last 15 years it's like
give back to Beloit what they gave Ken
and I which was opportunity
to be able to you know bank for us our
banks in Beloit gave us that chance the
people in Beloit you know they uh
they supported our growth
it's just a great community and so I I
just have found it very rewarding to be
able to help Beloit be the city they
always wanted to be it was made up of
great people
but it was always a Foundry City that
lost a lot of its companies
in the last 30 years
and they were always struggling
and it's really my turn my time
to be able to develop it into a city
that's a little Jewel it's not
philanthropy
a couple of things are but basically
it's it's putting Revival back in a
tired town
that got left behind when Industries
changed in manufacturing left and it was
difficult to watch the city I loved
which is only 35 000 people
you know really start to suffer I know
there's been manufacturing Investments
that you've been that you made in
schools but more recently there's the
Lincoln School can you tell me about it
a public school system across the nation
has major problems and especially in in
Beloit they've they've suffered
in the school system
the numbers that children are graduating
and their ability to get on with their
life
it's very difficult very difficult
um
so it got to the point that the only way
that we could really help
is to put competition
in the city and to actually start a
school build a school
and embrace educating the children so
that they don't just graduate
but they graduate
with with knowledge and we're doing that
we're one year old
and
in math we doubled what they had learned
a 200 percent
in one year
so um the school in three years will be
from K4 all the way to 12. and so we'll
get to having a full school it's it's
built for all of the children
and we will right now we're 530 children
entering School
huge waiting line to get in sad I wish I
could grow it faster but you know I've
got to hire the teachers you've got to
end the curriculum is we're teaching the
basics
and uh yeah hire the right people hire
the right people hire the and make sure
you teach them what they need to know so
the the mission for our school is that
you will graduate and you will already
know a career maybe nursing because we
do a lot of vocational training in
teaching the whole lower level is all
about vocational
and that's it's a forgotten need in our
in our nation educating kids how to be
contractors how to uh you know
be in the electronic world I mean we're
bringing it all in there you can
it's it's fabulous what we're doing
there with kids you know you've got to
have a future and we we build futures
for children
and we talk about it when they're four
years old we already talk about what do
you dream about what do you think you
want to be when you grow up what did you
want to be when you grew up I mean we're
talking here for the 50 over 50 and I
love asking people did you ever imagine
you're over 50 career when you were a
teen or in your 20s I
I tell this story when I
as I remember the day I stood at the
window in The Farmhouse
and thought I'm not I don't want to be a
farmer I don't want to marry a farmer
I was 10. and I dreamed about wearing
that blue suit
and going to the city I lived in Osseo
Wisconsin
I the city I wanted to go to was
Minneapolis because it was the biggest
city close by and my two older sisters
one was working up there already so you
know I'm one of nine so I was in the
middle
um so what number are you I have number
four or yeah my dad is four of nine four
of nine yeah
so it's you know there's a lot of us in
the middle but it's all good but you do
dream if you don't dream you don't have
a goal you don't know where you're going
to go
you have to have to think about your
future and I think thinking about your
future the Younger You Are
the more you start looking at at those
careers you just notice what's going on
in life
you're exposed to it I knew what I
didn't want to do and I have here I Live
Now in the country I have horses I have
all the things I said I wasn't going to
do
yeah I don't milk cows I but I do love
nature I love nature I love being
outside so you can you know the old
saying you can take the girl out of the
country you can't take the country out
of the girl and uh and I'm living proof
of that is there enough a moment as you
look at your career that you think
you almost gave up you wanted to just
throw no way no oh no all right I've got
I think three signs in my office
that tell me never to quit
I you quit you're done doesn't matter
what it is
I don't believe in quitting now I'm
facing oh life life on this Earth is I
I'm not done
you know that's the most frustrating
part I think of getting old is golly
there's still so much
so much to do
what do you want to do
more
more education more for the school
more for the people that have helped me
you know just to give back in many ways
I can't change the world
but there's so many things I can do with
medicine
I'm really involved in a company called
Northstar I've been involved in it for
14 years
and it's just coming to its own I mean a
cure for cancer
and I can actually see it I can see it
it's all about Isotopes and new medicine
it's it's good stuff I want to be there
it's being over 50 an advantage or
disadvantage in your line of work I
think it's helped
there's not an experience that I didn't
learn something from so I think that's
good you know
I enjoyed being under 50. you know I was
working when I was 21 and I was working
when I was 20. oh
I just think there's a lot you can learn
in life and I have learned a lot I
didn't go to college I had to learn I
had to learn what I know
you know whether it be hard knocks or by
mistake
but you learn and you carry that that
knowledge with you speaking of
experience you have seen your business
through a number of different economic
Times and we are talking in a moment
where it was just reported that new home
sales fell in July to a six and a half
year low there's a lot of uncertainty
out there in the market I first want to
ask you about the business how are you
feeling about I know you have different
lines of business but given the broader
economic environment what's your outlook
definitely we're going into a recession
we're probably already there
whoever keeps score on that
um
from what I'm hearing
it's not going to be as hard as the
recession of 8 9 10. that was long and
that was hard
I'm hoping that we don't have to go
through that
it won't be as hard are we preparing for
it absolutely I was going to ask what's
your advice for female entrepreneurs or
just younger women in general who are
seeing this economic uncertainty and
feeling that uncertainty in their own
career it's hard for me to separate
myself by gender I my saying is when I
go to work I just park my gender at the
door
almost all the businesses I'm involved
in
are
more male Industries I mean they're
manufacturing and extruding and
they're all I don't have
any industry
North Star
as as a lot of females I mean that's a
high-tech industry
and there's no gender specific there at
the end the reason I qualify that is
I can do any job I want but don't
expect me I I can't I'm not strong I'm
Different you know so I separated by you
know physical type
so I mean I there's limitations
so
we employ a lot of men in the industries
that we have
so your question
was how do I see it for women it's hard
for me to look through that lens
it's going to be it's going to hurt
everybody
everybody
I mean recession is never good
but um
I I can't I honestly I can't separate
the genders on how this recession is
going to hit
that's fair I just can't I can't do that
um
can't do that
well I will ask you another gender
question because we have called you the
richest self-made one of the richest
self-made women in America what does
that mean to you what does it feel like
to be among that rarified group well I
never quit
I work hard I um I get asked all the
time why do you still go to work
you're ancient
my kids and and you know like Mom you
know why are you still going to work
you're 75 years old
it's like I I'm healthy I love what I do
I'm still growing companies
why would I
why would I quit why would I not be
there
I like it I like business I know there's
more I can do I just you know like
everybody the clock is ticking I gotta
hurry up and get it done
so I'm I'm working at it I think doing
things for mankind like the North Star
business
it's important to me really important to
me I ran and put on my PIN on my suit
because
I love this country
an opportunity
is here and I'm
just so blessed to Born been born in
America
was I never had a door that didn't
didn't open for me I never thought about
being a female
and not being able to do what I do I I
don't give advice usually people have to
figure things out themselves but I I
tell my children just you know if you
want to do that just do it you know
don't let think of why women aren't in
that you know the other thing that'll
hold you back is if you're not
physically strong enough to do certain
tasks
and that stops me from I never wanted to
be a shingler I didn't want to put the
apply the roofing it way too much work
for me so I think you know so much of
our choices as females is I
go in there and you want to be a doctor
be a doctor you know you want to run
north star our Nuclear Pharmacy company
this is just the intelligence and the
ability and your drive
as an individual to pursue your dreams
I learned industries that I never
thought I would be involved in
I love construction I love the but I'm
not a contractor
but do I want that company to survive do
we have women that are actually I've got
women that enjoy being in the
construction Arena that's fabulous
that's fabulous
you know they can supervise a big job
they're doing great so I mean it's
I I think the sky's the limit for women
this has been so insightful Diane thank
you so much for joining us
thank you for having me appreciate it